françois cocq essayiste et auteur et
jean petaux politologue bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france l'allemagne
on le voit mais aussi l'italie l'espagne
le royaume-uni l'ont tous fait
différemment ils ont tous rendu hommage
à leurs victimes
est ce qu'on doit emboîter le pas en
france rendre hommage enfin ou aux cent
mille victimes maintenant du pays 19 1
françois cocq oui écoutez je suis pas
sûr que ce soit tant le fond de la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui que le
fait que la demande se pose aujourd'hui
justement nous savons bien qu'il ya
besoin dans nos sociétés d'avoir ces
moments de mémoire de se retrouver
autour de cause commune et finalement
que la communauté omen des citoyens
puissent avoir des points de passage qui
permettent de ne pas oublier ce qui
s'est passé et qui permettent de se
ressouder et de se refonder au fur et à
mesure de notre propre évolution
donc je pense que la question de la
commémoration viendra mais elle doit
venir au moment le plus opportun
et est ce que le moment le plus opportun
est aujourd'hui ça c'est une autre
question est ce que aujourd'hui nous
pouvons considérer que cette phase du
corps d'un virus est suffisamment
derrière nous pour pouvoir nous projeter
déjà dans l'après en commémorant ce qui
s'est passé mais en n'ayant pas un
regard sur ce qui va advenir dans les
mois et semaines qui viennent
est ce que ces commémorations ne se
contentent de parler de celles et ceux
qui sont victimes du coronavirus
directement mais ce qu'elle ne mette pas
finalement de côté toutes celles et tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui encore dans leur
chair vive et subissent le fait que
l'hôpital est tellement déstructuré
aujourd'hui avec la crise du covin que
certain nombre d'opérations sont
repoussés et que certains hummer de
pathologies qui n'ont rien à voir avec
le comique il ya beaucoup de questions
aujourd'hui et il me semble que cette
question est assez inopportune au moment
où elle est posée ce qui ne veut pas
dire qu'elle ne devra pas être posée
mais le moment venu et je ne voudrais
surtout pas que cette question soit
posée aujourd'hui du fait d'un parallèle
qui ne serait pas tout à fait adéquat
avec ce qui se passe dans les autres
pays parce que la france n'est pas
frappé dans la même violence parce que
le l'exécutif n'a pas fait les mêmes
choix politiques que les autres pays
notamment au mois de janvier donc nous
avons subi une troisième vague beaucoup
plus fort notre pays qu'ailleurs et donc
il ne faudrait pas qu'ils aient un
mimétisme qui nous conduisent
aujourd'hui à mettre en place cette
commémoration
nous devrions nous donner le temps de la
faire de manière apaisée de la mettre en
place de manière apaisée et d'emmener
avec nous l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
puisque vous parlez d'un moment opportun
ce qu'on peut estimer jean petaux qu'il
ya un moment réellement opportun pour
rendre hommage aux victimes de coheed ce
que vous êtes d'accord vous avec un
françois cocq à écouter france acadie a
dit beaucoup de choses je partage
d'ailleurs bonne partie de son propos
mais c'est vrai que avant que je réponds
sur la question de l'opportunité moi je
voudrais aussi dire quelques mots sur
sur le principe même un bon le principe
d'une commémoration
ou alors il faut changer non hein c'est
ça renvoie la mémoire un port de fait la
mémoire d'une séquence qui n'est pas
achevée c'est un peu particulier il ya
un côté un petit peu paradoxale la dent
dans l'emploi des termes un alors le
terme un hommage est peut-être plus
adéquat
je me demande si l'opportunité n'est pas
provoquée par à la fois une forme de
mimétisme évidemment alors quelqu'un là
c'est quand même pas forcément une bonne
une bonne peut-être la meilleure d'aider
des postures des options possibles mais
peut-être aussi que dès qu'elle est
provoqué par malheureusement vous allez
dire la sécheresse des chiffres vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure dans le
reportage que auquel on a assisté en
allemagne vous avez évoqué le chiffre de
90 mille morts
1 si j'ai bien entendu on arrive entre
l'an 1000 la 80 mille morts voilà or il
se trouve que la france je pense vient
de franchir le cap des 100 milles 1
comme s'il y avait jailli tire un espèce
de seuil si je ferais que passer 7,7
cette limite on se devrait de le rentrer
dans une forme de manifestations
collectives en tout ça et est un peu je
les vire artificielle de mon point de
vue je crois que ce qu'il serait
peut-être plus juste en tous les cas le
plus plus cohérent de de réfléchir en
particulier à celles et ceux qui depuis
maintenant un an
parce qu'ils sont comme on dit en
première ligne soignants etc
ont eu des gros problèmes de santé ça pu
avoir des effets par rapport à des
enfants qui ont pu perdre par exemple un
proche parent et que là par exemple la
question très concrète de obtienne ses
enfants le statut de pupille de la
nation pourrait être abordé à mon sens
puisque les termites et si c'est aussi
une demande c'est aussi une demande des
familles des victimes
réunis dans l'association des victimes
du colis de 19 depuis avril 2020 ces
familles dont denis réclame quand même
un deuil national
depuis déjà plusieurs mois est ce qu'on
appela tout même à on devrait écouter
ces familles endeuillées
est-ce qu'on n'a pas un train de retard
françois cocq alors il faut bien sûr
toujours écouté les associations qui
sont les plus proches du terrain et pour
autant vous venez de le dire les
familles demandent des choses qui
peuvent être discutés elle demande un
deuil national
mais elle ne demande pas forcément ça
vient d'être ré rappelle là aussi par
argent plutôt c'est très important
une commémoration fait c'est à dire
quelque chose qui renvoie à la mémoire
nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui dans
cette phase là ce que nous avons à faire
aujourd'hui une autre tâche à tous c'est
de travailler au présent et en pensant
l'avenir là on est déjà en train de se
retourner sur le passé comme si on
voulait nous faire croire que la crise
est derrière nous ce n'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas vrai en allemagne m une
commémoration aujourd'hui en place en
tout cas il ya eu des cérémonies en
place aujourd'hui
mais l'allemagne entendait le et frappé
aujourd'hui deux fois moins violemment
que la france c'est à dire que chaque
jour il y à 250 personnes qui sont
contaminées pour un million en allemagne
quand nous sommes à 520 en france le
royaume uni a dansé à ériger un mémorial
il ya vingt fois moins de clients et
frappé lui aussi par cette épidémie
l'allemagne frappé aussi par cette
épidémie très fortement aux filles elles
envisagent de cession de ses parts ce
n'est pas parce que monsieur castex où
monsieur macron répète depuis des
semaines et des semaines que nous
faisons tout mieux que les autres qu'ils
ont raison et qu'il dise la vérité
c'est un mensonge l'allemagne est frappé
bien moins fortement que nous
aujourd'hui parce que l'allemagne mois
de janvier a pris des mesures pour est
dans une stratégie sinon 0 qu'ovide du
moins pour tracer et poursuivre les
différents cas ça n'a pas été le choix
personnel du président macron
le niveau est sans comparaison entre la
france et l'allemagne dans un rapport de
1 à 2 donc il ne faut pas aujourd'hui se
calquer sur l'allemagne pour se
précipiter dans des commémorations nous
nous avons une tâche aujourd'hui c'est
de faire face à une crise sanitaire de
grande ampleur il faudrait se concentrer
sur cela et prendre soin je suis
d'accord avec monsieur plutôt à la fois
de celles et ceux qui sont en première
ligne les premiers de corvée les
soignants en premier chef et toutes
celles et tous ceux qui devraient être
ciblés par la stratégie vaccinale comme
par exemple les enseignants à celle de
ceux qui sont les plus exposés et puis
aussi les familles parce que les
familles sont concernées quand le
président bak rond on nous dit qu'il
faut faire des transferts d'un endroit à
l'autre de la france est bien le rapport
à la mort
le rapport à l'accompagnement de chacun
de ces deux de ses proches doit être
doit être traité ça se traite pas à
coups de commémoration il faut être dans
une dimension bien plus humaine que dans
une visée politique
alors justement emmanuel macron il a il
s'est fendu d'un tweet quand même qui
fait polémique emmanuel macron et il a
rendu hommage aux 100000 morts français
de lakovic 19 500 comptes twitter c'est
un message qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue par les internautes qui l'ont
accusé de fêter un chiffre un
anniversaire un jean petaux mais moi je
veux pas du tout rentrer dans un dans
une position politique et je me garderai
bien de en particulier de deux
d'intervenir pour rajouter aux
propositions de solutions je n'ai pas du
tout la compétence pour ça ce que je
constate c'est que et là vous venez de
le rappeler la communication dans ce
genre de circonstance et surtout avec
les outils contemporains actuelle est
extrêmement dangereuse j'allais dire en
tous les cas risque est plutôt risqué et
elle peut très vite se retourner contre
contre tout auteur de messages a
fortiori à fortiori sur le président de
république qui dans d'autres systèmes
appareil est le seul le paratonnerre qui
prend tout à fait voilà donc où il me
semble que réfléchissons peut-être
l'ensemble de la société ah ah ah ce qui
est pour nous un vrai enjeu c'est à dire
la relation à la mort et voilà ce que ça
renvoie devrait renvoyer un travail tout
à fait passionnant un livre de jean
pierre lopes
il ya publié intitulé la société malade
c'est un peu un bilan au bout d'un an de
7 2 7 6
et c'est très intéressant de considérer
finalement en laponie et injectant les
diables révélateur contradictions tout
nous d'où leur et de toutes nos familles
en france précisément vous dit qu'il
faudrait prendre le temps et c'est ce
que disent d'ailleurs aussi les
psychologues de réfléchir de ne pas
s'arrêter aux chiffres et de réfléchir
de réfléchir à une forme d'hommage
justement pour aller au delà
françois coop oui mais justement vous
voyez vous voyez que on a un problème
j'ai commencé par ça en disant qu'il y
avait un problème dans les temporalités
tout le monde voit bien aujourd'hui que
cette question de la commémoration en
france et reposer de manière un petit
peu insidieuse par le gouvernement alors
j'ai bien noté que certains avaient
d'autres intérêts je sais que c'est le
député orphelins qui est tête de liste
pour les régionales dans les pays de
loire qui a fait une proposition de loi
en ce sens tous ces gens là ont des
intérêts politiciens mais le
gouvernement saisit la balle au bond
parce que monsieur macro est dans une
séquence qui la séquence du
déconfinement il veut faire en sorte de
nous faire croire que cette épidémie est
derrière et que finalement c'est lui qui
nous en a sorti et bien évidemment le
fait de pouvoir parler aujourd'hui de
vouloir imposer un moment de
commémoration dans cette période qui est
une séquence non terminée d'un point de
vue sanitaire mais qu'il voudrait qu
lors d'un point de vue politique fait
partie de la stratégie
communicationnelle qu'il met en place et
je crois que nous autres peuples
français méritons mieux que ça ces
commémorations il faudra les vivres les
mettre en place le moment le moment venu
mais ça doit être un moment de concorde
nationale d'apaisement et de
construction du commun et pas quelque
chose qui pourrait être vécu une fois
encore comme une division matières
foeller le député du maine et loire qui
a proposé la journée du 17 mars journée
nationale d'hommage aux victimes
il existe
une journée similaire en italie
jean petaux est ce qu'on peut reprocher
vous croyez vous à la classe politique
forme de récupération
la classe politique est elle fait de la
politique j'enfonce une porte ouverte
en disant ça donc on ne s'agit pas de
savoir si c'est une récupération où
effectivement d d d d d d d d des coups
politiques qui sont qui sont ainsi
engagés on voulait pas vous avez pas
empêché la lada la classe politique
comme vous l'a désigné une expression
qui je vous laisse la responsabilité de
faire j'allais dire quelque part son
sens son métier 1 c'est à dire de faire
la politique
ce qui est certain et là je rejoins ce
qu'a dit ce que dit françois cocq c'est
que il y a des télescopages dans les
agendas
1 parce qu'on peut aussi imaginer que
l'horizon politique qui est maintenant
pratiquement obsessionnelle pour la
quasi totalité des formations c'est
celui de mad d'avril même île de 2022
donc certes un certain 20 la plupart se
positionne effectivement en faisant très
attention à ne pas manquer des séquences
ou de manquer des prises de position de
manquer des rendez vous au contraire en
faisant très attention à ne pas déraper
sur telle ou telle situation
parce que il apparaît clairement que
tout le monde est attendu au tournant si
je puis dire le moindre la moindre faute
de carre la moindre le moindre dérapage
sur ce sujet extrêmement sensible de la
cote vide va avoir des conséquences
politiques pour celle ou celui qui vote
que m donc il faut sans doute s'attendre
à la fois à une surenchère ça ça risque
d'être assez terrible à vivre à une
surenchère dans l'émotionnel dans le le
le la volonté de d'apparaître comme
ayant à coeur
et puis aussi une forme de surveillance
des propos des uns et des autres pour
les tacles et à la première occasion
ça va pas participer je pense à rendre
intelligent le débat politique
d'ici les prochains mois françois cocq
sera sur cette question de la
récupération politique
oui je vous le disais on voit bien
surtout que c'est le gouvernement qui
est à la manoeuvre de manière de manière
assez cynique parce qu'il ya quand même
un autre point qui est posée en général
les commémorations arriver où je le
disais en fun à la fin d'une séquence
sauf que cette séquence n'est pas
terminée autrement dit celles et ceux
qui mettraient en place cette
commémoration au nom de l'état sans en
même temps les fauteurs de troubles ce
sont celles et ceux qui ont géré la
crise
quelqu'un a été gérée depuis un an c'est
à dire de manière catastrophique dans ce
pays du moment des masques à l'épisode
des vaccins que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui jusqu'à la décision
personnelle de monsieur macron le 29
janvier de laisser aller le virus est
donc de nous amener à un seuil qui est
au dessus de celui de tous nos voisins
de tous les pays limitrophes delà de la
france donc ça cause d'un problème
aujourd'hui il n'ya pas le recul est
d'une certaine façon il n'ya pas la
légitimité suffisante pour l'exécutif
pour imposer ce moment de commémoration
il me semble donc malvenu de se
précipiter en état sauf à penser qu'on
va continuer à s'enfoncer dans la crise
démocratique dans ces hiatus de
légitimité permanent qui engendre à
chaque fois un peu plus de perte de
consentement au sein de notre population
nous avons besoin de recréer du commun
nous avons besoin d'un moment de re
fondation populaire et dans moins de
refondation institutionnelle aussi est
de reconstruire le pays et je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit avec des décisions
précipitées qui ont un arrière fond
politiciens que nous y parvenions et
pour revenir justement aux familles des
victimes
on ne sait pas comment cette pandémie va
évoluer on a pris beaucoup de retard en
france
concernant la campagne de vaccination
donc le risque est effectivement cessé
de voir encore le nombre de décès
augmente et en france un moment donné
avec toutes les incertitudes est ce
qu'il faudra pas prendre une décision à
ce niveau
pour justement permettre à ces familles
endeuillées de faire le deuil
écoutez moi je veux pas me projeter un
an dans dans l'avenir on voit bien
d'ailleurs que ce qui caractérise
fictivement la période depuis le le mois
de mars 2000 2020 c'est une très grande
incapacité à se donner des objectifs des
échéances
voyez on a on a évoqué la la date de mi
mai comme étant susceptible de permettre
un retour à un début de normalité
tout cela est totalement j'allais dire
délétères d'une certaine façon est très
est très instable
voilà un donc je comprends bien tous les
propos de françois cocq moi moi je je je
n'ai pas peut-être son talent de
polémiste ou d'essayiste et je ne jeûne
adopterait pas là
le lam mgd dire direction dans dans la
dans les mises en cause ont tous les
cadres dans les attaques je crois
qu'elle il faut les autres il faut les
entendre
je crois aussi par ailleurs je suis
l'avocat de personnes que tout les la
certitude que l'on peut avoir c'est que
les décideurs politiques en ce moment
quels qu'ils soient sont forcément la
cible des critiques il c'est bien normal
parce que c'est quelque part sur eux que
repose la responsabilité et que repose
la responsabilité de la décision mais je
vois pas exactement qui pourrait
proposer des solutions miracles très
différentes pour thème à l'étranger même
à l'étranger on voit bien que regarder
les la réaction des länder à la volonté
de la chancelière
là encore ça de rapidement françois
cancon peu plus justement sur cet avenir
incertain
en quelques mots oui malbon clair il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de perspective qui
est tracé
on voit bien que les dates qui sont
donnés sont sans cesse repoussées il n'y
a pas de visibilité et surtout on a
l'impression que l'exécutif n'a pas la
main sur l'épidémie est donc ça ça ne
permet pas aux uns et aux autres de
pouvoir penser l'avenir dans une
difficulté à se projeter dans l'avenir
d'où le problème que ces cocos
commémoration pause et pour le dire
autrement on a aussi un problème au sein
de nos sociétés
c'est que l'exécutif le président macron
à trop avoir fait peser les raisons de
cette épidémie sur la responsabilité
individuelle a engendré ce principe
absurde d'acceptabilité qui n'a rien à
voir avec le consentement mais qui
renvoie chacun à sa décision
individuelle et finalement c'est
l'irresponsabilité ou l'invité qui
émergent et on ne peut pas fonctionner
dans une situation merci les
responsables sont devenus et se protège
par leurs propres responsabilités
on a besoin aujourd'hui que le peuple
finalement puisse reprendre en main sa
souveraineté mercouri je serai seul cas
du secteur
merci françois cocq essayiste et auteur
merci à vous jean petaux politologue